on va aller au pied camp de base donc à
4900 mètres d'altitude
on va passer la nuit pour te nuit pour
se réveiller à une heure du matin est
monté au sommet du glacier du pic et
avoir une vue j'espère imprenable s'il
faut aussi beaucoup aujourd'hui ça
risque d'être vraiment génial ils vont
mener deux cracks du tout pour vous
qu'on fait ça tous les jours des trois
quilles puisque trois heures de marche
l'entraînement et c'est le camp de base
je suis en attente il est 7 heures et on
va se coucher si vite que possible pour
se relever
demain nuit kruta départ miller
apparemment l'équipe devra cependant les
semaines doit le sommet du pic à 1 6291
comme ça
m d'altitude crossword et des morts je
pense que c'est demain que je suis très
excité dormir fait bien froid -10° de
mort non réveil va pas falloir subir ça
mais
[Musique]
on a plus de 5500 là et on continue la
montée bien délicate vers deux sommets
des rings pic et quand vous voyez je
pense qu'on peut le voir l'image une
partie super difficile où on escalade
on voit les gens passionnants au plus
tôt et que c'est dur au [ __ ] que c'est
du rallye mais pas un grand ciel bleu
soleil tu fait vachement froid j - p g
un doigt à 5000 6000 series 1650 mètres
d'altitude
il est très dur comme en france avoir
déjà dit malgré tout été c'est pas la
grande forme
quand les chiites
c'est juste incroyable c'est juste trop
trop trop beau on a les siennes des
montagnes de lever de soleil les gens
fatigués et les chaînes de montagnes nos
décidément td dinho lcd pour décor un
nouveau numéro 5700 5800 et maintenant
on marque sur la neige de culture et où
sa voix sinon t'es tu ce que serait
l'avenir imprenable il fait super beau
c'est juste génial sauf bien sûr je suis
épuisé il de rester près 300 m de
dénivelé
je visais c'est super facilement il y à
en alimenter les fruits
ok maintenant on doit être à 5,9 le
soleil est là bas c'est un peu loin de
sanguinet le truc c'est qu'il faut
traverser une crevasse c'est exister ici
est un truc de malade
cisco et j
[Musique]
faire ici des sommets et éclairer là où
on n'est plus qu'à 300 mètres d'altitude
de fait même moi juste incroyable du
paysage ou yards et cette neige est là
on est en train de se rapprocher au
niveau des sherpas qui sont nos actions
seront plantés sont en train de tenter
des décors de pouvoir faciliter
l'installation finale
et voilà c'est un monstrueux en ce
qu'ils font les choix et lucky femme
noire c'est juste trop fou
votre autre bouteille n'est pas loin du
soleil certaines aventures de génial
crois que c'est tellement beau jour de
vacances j'ai toujours des risques versé
que j'ai eu transfert
monk la plupart des gens mais qu'au fond
on est passé à cinq milles 7 8
j'étais très très très mal un jeu normal
de crohn voilà il y avait deux qui ont
abandonné
franchement je ne sais pas s'ils vont
devoir abandonner
et bizarrement en fait une fois qu'on a
passé quelques croise on a fait quelques
trucs vraiment fou ça va super bien
une forme rien et je vais quand même pas
les feux de l'altitude à peine ça va
très très bien
là on a projeté 6 millimètres ont
regardé la série de la carotte de glace
épuisant à pointer ultra ride
j'entendais les gens galèrent vraiment
beaucoup
c'est la dernière étape un dernier
effort et qu'est-ce qu'il est dur qu'est
ce que c'est dieu bon français pas de
prendre l'habitude ça s'appelle mais par
contre que coucou tout ce que vous
voulez c'est super dur
la ja la spa f.mi trois manquent au
monde
[Applaudissements]
à vantaa oua devenue une résine jouer
aux échecs palin et sans lequel six
nageurs mais kamenar
[Musique]
et
bien en venir au camp de base pour vous
amener en eau du half pipe
je suis épuisé c'est même pire que ça
comme voyager respect de tous et si vous
me dire que ça encore géants prétendent
avoir des hallucinations d'avoir des
hallucinations
nerveux
ding jim tourner complètement folle hier
avoir des annonces pic
c'était juste comme vous avez pu
entendre hier je n'ai vraiment pas les
capacités physiques parler un peu
partout cgt j'étais vraiment bien et
lord et ça va beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui
bien récupérer ces entraves à quel point
je peux récupérer après une journée
complètement folle hier 17 heures de
marche
en une journée de 1h du matin jusqu'à ou
en 1h02 pire je suis arrivé à la fin et
des petites 9h30 comme ça une bonne
pause d'une heure une fois qu'on est
arrivé au camp de base
j'ai bien dormi il s'agit de me
récupérer gicquel journée de folie puis
un énorme merci mon cher papa il ya un
truc c'est ces gens sont juste
incroyables sont monstrueux que les
grâce aux hits est vraiment à nos soins
ils vont aider techniquement bien sûr
moralement mais aussi nous la sécurité
avec sentiront en sécurité
heureusement parce que montanier c'est
super super super bons joueurs